let's continue the earl thomas
conversation chris from the perspective
of future options we mentioned on the
way out on pft live that mike mccarthy
the cowboys coach speaking of reporters
today said that he's very confident with
his roster here's the quote courtesy of
clarence hill of the fort worth star
telegram we're very confident where we
are as far as the 80-man roster as far
as any prospect that's available
those are more conversations for jerry
jones stephen jones and will mcclay as
far as looking at that situation i have
nothing really to report so
the door's not shut right but mccarthy's
saying hey i'm fine with who i have
uh if you read between the lines you can
maybe see mccarthy saying
probably not something we're looking for
but again it's it's above his pay grade
literally to make those decisions yeah
no it definitely is and we know they
have flirted with earl thomas in the
past before earl thomas you know being a
a texas longhorn
i mean the two biggest entities in that
state are the texas longhorn and the
dallas cowboys so i understand him
wanting to go there and all that but you
know as we talked about on the show you
know one
this is a cowboy team that's you know
got a lot of things to be happy about on
the roster do we want to bring in uh you
know
an an older
star hall of fame type player that's
past his prime
that certainly seems to be somewhat of
an annoyance in the last two locker
rooms he was in so do you want to deal
with that and then the big thing too is
you know chris richards not there
anymore or they're not running that
seattle defense mike nolan's there so i
don't know if they fancy the type of
player that he is for that scheme and
the fit and all that like they used to
in the old days so it'll be interesting
i really am intrigued to see who gets
involved in this earl thomas
conversation
yeah and uh the atlanta falcons dan
quinn says no and that's where we start
pushing back on this idea that because
somebody played with somebody worked
with somebody that means they're going
to want to work together again well no
there's a chance that dan quinn looks at
and says i'm i've done my time with earl
thomas and if earl thomas isn't the
player that he was several years ago
it's like the antonio brown dynamic
you'll deal with the personality as long
as the player is off the charts great
exactly when the player starts to dip we
don't want to deal with the person and
for dan quinn to come out today and say
affirmatively no earl thomas in atlanta
they run that defense for crying out
loud yeah um that that's that's
another
red flag
to do your homework talk to your friends
tap your network
do your research and find out exactly
what went down with earl thomas in
seattle and baltimore before you go out
on a limb well exactly right you know
and again like earl thomas amazing
player hall of famer i mean you know a
part of a special defense we we talked
about all that but the simple reality of
the situation is right now in this point
of his career
he's not as good as ricardo allen or
kean o'neill he can't start over them
they're better than him you know there's
going to be a number of teams where i
think you know the normal casual
everyday fans going to look at it and go
why wouldn't we want earl thomas why
wouldn't we honor old thomas because
he's still a a big name and flashing
lights and we he's a household name
but but the reality to me
and again you know i'm ron jaworski and
i watch the film and all that crap you
know yeah we're talking about a middle
of the pack and i mean not like on the
edge of like ooh that you know he's just
in the middle of the pack
just on the edge of the cream of the
crop no no he is severely entrenched in
the middle of the pack maybe in the back
end of the middle of the pack where he
is at this part of his career so that's
where i just think it's going to be hard
too between the attitude the play you
know what kind of price is he going to
demand all of those things i think are
going to make teams question a little
bit
unless you feel bad for earl thomas he
got 20 million dollars from the ravens
for one year with the team and he has at
least an effort a claim a possibility of
another 10 million depending upon how
the inevitable grievance unfolds between
the ravens and the national football
league players association
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports